ahora que ya lo sabemos todo sobre los
ácidos fuertes por ejemplo que el ácido
clorhídrico
hcl es de kim en una solución acuosa en
una solución acuosa es un ácido fuerte
porque se disocia completamente en bueno
unión de hidrógeno ok el cual también
está en una solución acuosa de lujo más
unión o una unión de cloro un anillo con
cloruro dejando así el cual también va a
estar en una solución acuosa y bueno
este de aquí es un ácido según la
definición de reinos porque está
incrementando la concentración de
hidrógeno en el agua justo estos
hidrógenos es un ácido según browne
usted laurie porque el ácido clorhídrico
está donando sus protones de hidrógeno y
por último es un ácido según lewis
porque al disociarse el ácido
clorhídrico el cloruro está tomando los
electrones para sí mismo es decir es una
sector de electrones
y esa es la otra razón por la cual es un
ácido según la definición de lewis pero
en cualquier caso se disocia por
completo y por lo tanto es considerado
un ácido fuerte ahora si llamo a éste un
ácido fuerte por consecuencia debe de
existir algo que se llame un ácido débil
y bueno un ácido débil va a ser aquí
justo déjame ponerlo con este acento que
no se va a disociar por completo
entonces eran para poner un ejemplo
digamos que nos tomamos ácido
fluorhídrico dejaron algo así aquí tengo
un poco de ácido de h efe o que
integramos escribirlo con este color
efe el cual va a estar en una solución
acuosa así que tenemos cribado con este
color en una solución acuosa y bueno
cuando se disocia este ácido
fluorhídrico se va de social sólo un
poco por lo tanto por aquí vamos a tener
algo de estos iones de hidrógeno algo de
estos también en una solución acuosa
déjame escribirlo así ya esto le vamos a
agregar millones o más bien uniones de
flúor dejan ponerlo con este color flúor
ok y negativo el cual también está en
una solución acuosa es decir se van a
desprender un poco de
este ácido que tenemos aquí y bueno de
modo que esto es un asiduo débil y por
lo tanto no va a ir solamente en una
dirección esta reacción es la reacción
de iovine en dos direcciones va a ir en
una dirección hacia acá y en otra
dirección hacia acá es decir está en
equilibrio y entonces estas dos especies
existen en nuestra molécula es decir
tenemos una reacción en equilibrio que
va en ambas direcciones
ahora bien por otro lado te podés
preguntar si el flúor y el cloro son
halógenos entonces porque el ácido
clorhídrico es un ácido fuerte mientras
que el ácido fluorhídrico es una actitud
débil y para eso dejamos subir un poco
la pantalla porque quiero que veas
nuestra tabla periódica aquí por acá
arriba tenemos el hidrógeno justo por
aquí voy a poner esta tabla por aquí
tenemos al hidrógeno que le gusta
bastante crear enlaces por otra parte
recuerda que todos estos que están abajo
del hidrógeno todos estos que tengo aquí
son metales alcalinos es decir tiene
un electrón de valencia todos estos
tienen un electrón de valencia y por lo
tanto simple y sencillamente quieren
dejarlo y bueno pues dárselo a estos que
tenemos aquí entonces si tienes alguno
de estos elementos que están en el
periodo 2 debajo de él es decir los que
están abajo del nitrógeno y los mezclas
con algunos de los que tenemos acá con
algún halógeno
normalmente se va a formar una sal
iónica donde éste regala un electrón y
este otro lo acepta de modo que así ya
tienes un compuesto iónico sin embargo
el hidrógeno es un poco diferente es
diferente ya que tienes solamente un
electrón en su última capa en su capa
más externa en realidad sólo tiene una
capa pero la primera capa es interesante
porque está completa cuando sólo tiene
dos electrones estos elementos de aquí
no habrán estado felices y estás un
electrón sin embargo si le das un
electrón al de hidrógeno el si está
bastante contento de modo que cuando el
hidrógeno se mezcla con estos que
tenemos aquí con estos de aquí
o sea completamente el electrón es decir
cuando el hidrógeno forma enlaces con
estos que tenemos aquí a estos déjenme
ponerlos con este color estos de aquí
bueno lo que va a pasar es lo siguiente
el nitrógeno no va a ceder por completo
su electrón porque el hidrógeno dice si
me das parte de tu electrón entonces
llegó a 2 y si compartes el electrón
bueno tú vas a llegar a 8 así que en
definitiva nos conviene hacer el enlace
con estos elementos que tengo aquí pero
ojo no le da en el electrón por completo
ahora curiosamente cuando nosotros
juntamos al hidrógeno con el cloro con
el bromo o con el yodo es decir el ácido
clorhídrico el ácido clorhídrico y el
ácido clorhídrico espero que esté
diciendo bien a estos tres nos va a dar
ácidos fuertes cuando el hidrógeno se
junta con alguno de estos tres eso
quiere decir que se disocian
completamente en agua pero cuando el
hidrógeno se enlaza con el flúor justo
con este que tenemos aquí bueno pues lo
que va a pasar es que no se disocia por
cumplir
en el amor y la razón por la que pasa
esto es que es aún más electro negativo
por ejemplo si comparamos ácido
fluorhídrico a ácido clorhídrico y lo
comparamos con el ácido clorhídrico con
el ácido clorhídrico ok lo que va a
pasar es que este enlace va a ser mucho
más fuerte y déjame ponerlo así va a ser
mucho más fuerte que este enlace que
tenemos aquí y bueno mucho más me
refiero a la cantidad de energía que hay
en este enlace
ahora el ácido clorhídrico a su vez
tiene un enlace fuerte a comparación no
sé por ejemplo del ácido bromo bíblico
por acá si yo pongo aquí h br ok
antes de ponerlo así pueden el enlace
más débil más débil que esté y más débil
que esté así que estos enlaces son más
fáciles de romper de modo que cuando
hablamos del agua y para eso lo voy a
poner aquí aquí tengo un oxígeno y por
acá tengo un hidrógeno y por acá tengo a
mi otro hidrógeno
y ahora por acá tengo un par de
electrones por acá otro y bueno estos
electrones hacen que tenga una carga
parcial negativa la cual va a entrar a
estos hidrógenos para que quieran unirse
a esta molécula del agua para que se
disocien y se cuenten con esta molécula
del agua pero en el caso de flúor
también más tiene una necesidad de
disociarse para juntarse con esta
molécula le es tentador sin embargo
todavía le gusta estar dando vueltas por
ahí el oxígeno es muy electro negativo
pero también el flúor por lo que este
hidrógeno va a estar merodeando
alrededor de ambos así que no se disocia
completamente y esto es porque el ácido
fluorhídrico es un ácido débil mientras
que todos los demás ácidos halógenos son
fuertes y bueno ahora que ya sabemos por
qué es un ácido débil vamos a regresar a
lo que teníamos escrito aquí abajo vamos
a dejar nuestra tabla periódica porque
ahora voy a querer resolver lo siguiente
vamos a descubrir cuál es el ph cuando
disuelvo
1.5 molar déjame ponerlo con este color
1.5 ok molar molar de ácido
por hídrico y bueno esto por decir algo
obviamente por definición cómo se ha
dado esto en polaridad lo tengo en
alguna solución en este caso es una
solución acuosa ahora cada reacción de
equilibrio tiene una constante de
equilibrio o una constante ese es lo
cual lo hemos hablado varias veces y la
constante de equilibrio ampara esta
reacción la constante de equilibrio o la
constante de acidez le voy a poner para
el ácido clorhídrico am déjame
escribirlo así para el hf ok de esta
reacción quien es bueno pues esto es
exactamente igual que la multiplicación
de la concentración de los productos es
decir la concentración de h ok por la
concentración de flúor por la
concentración de
y a esto habrá que dividirlo entre la
concentración de los reactivos
es decir la concentración de este de
aquí del ácido fluorhídrico es decir de
http y ahora si buscamos el valor de
esta constante a 25 grados celsius que
es la temperatura ambiente entonces esta
constante de aquí toma el valor de 7 ok
por 10 elevado a la menos 4 entonces si
tengo 1.5 molar de hf podría averiguar
cuál es el ph pues la respuesta es que
si recuerda que esencialmente lo que
buscamos es la concentración de
hidrógeno ya que después de tomarnos el
logaritmo negativo de esto obtendremos
el p h de esta disolución así que vamos
a ver si podemos hacerlo y para eso
antes en bajar un poco la pantalla
porque quiero que veas lo siguiente si
yo me tomo justo por aquí si yo me tomo
1.5 molar
de ácido fluorhídrico entonces vamos a
suponer que una cierta cantidad de
concentración y vamos a llamarle una
cierta cantidad x de esa concentración
se disocia por lo tanto x molar se
disocia y si eso ocurre x molar de esto
se va a disociar para formar justo en
esto que tenemos aquí y entonces aquí
algo se disocia por lo tanto si estamos
en equilibrio entonces vamos a tener una
concentración ahora de fluoruro de
hidrógeno o de ácido clorhídrico de 1.5
molar 1.5 molar ok menos x que esa
cantidad molar que se disocia igual va
siendo concentración de hidrógeno bueno
pues es x molar estás de acuerdo
esta concentración va a ser x molar que
es la cantidad que este disocia y
entonces ésta también va a ser x molar y
que me entiendas eso es muy importante
si yo voy a disociar una molécula de
esta bueno pues voy a obtener uno de
estos y también voy a obtener uno de
estos y éstas serán las concentraciones
de equilibrio estás de acuerdo y creo
que puedes oler un poco de álgebra con
todo lo que vamos a hacer
continuación porque si estás ahora son
nuestras concentraciones de equilibrio
está x esta otra equis y 1.5 menos equis
entonces ahora si las podemos meter en
esta ecuación y con esto vamos a obtener
una ecuación que podemos resolver con
álgebra que podemos resolver para x así
que vamos a resolver le vamos a escribir
esto mismo aquí voy a empezar con esta
parte tengo 7 ok x 10 elevado a la menos
4 esto va a ser exactamente lo mismo que
y bueno sabemos la parte de abajo la
parte de abajo es decir la concentración
que tengo de ácido fluorhídrico en
equilibrio es lo mismo que 1.5 menos x
1.5 menos x en equilibrio esa es mi
concentración es decir la concentración
original que habíamos puesto menos la
concentración que se disocia y bueno
aquí arriba que me va a quedar la
concentración de hidrógeno que va a
salir de la cantidad que se disocia es
decir es
ok por la concentración de flúor que por
la misma razón es x
y ahora si te das cuenta aquí tengo una
ecuación que con pura álgebra podemos
resolver
déjeme bajar un poco la pantalla para
trabajarla ok vamos a quedarnos
solamente con esta parte de aquí porque
ahora que me va a quedar bueno
lo primero que quiero hacer es
multiplicar todo por 1.5 x así que me va
a quedar lo siguiente me va a quedar que
7 ok por 10 a la menos 4 ok esto que a
su vez multiplica y dgr ponerlo con este
color esto que a su vez multiplica a 1.5
menos equis ok esto va a ser exactamente
igual que x por x lo cual voy a ponerlo
con este color y sabemos que es x
cuadrada y buenos y ahora multiplicamos
7 por 10 al menos 4 por cada uno de lo
que está dentro de este paréntesis que
me va a quedar
bueno pues 7 por 10 será menos 4 si lo
distribuyó primero hay que multiplicarlo
por con 1.507 por 1.5 eso está fácil eso
es lo mismo que
10.5 es un ave con 10.5 10.5 por 10 a la
menos 4 por que lo escribe así 10 al
menos 4 ok y después me quedan menos x
que multiplica a 7 x dice la menos 4 y
lo voy a escribir con este color eso es
lo mismo que menos 7 ok menos 7 por 10
de la menos 4 por 10 a la menos 4 ok que
multiplica a x que la voy a escribir con
este color todas las x las voy a
escribir con color amarillo y esto va a
ser igual que x cuadrada y esto parece
tal vez un poco complicado sin embargo
date cuenta que es simplemente una
ecuación cuadrática y hay muchos vídeos
explicando este tipo de ecuaciones así
que si ponemos todo esto de este lado
derecho y lo igualamos a 0 para tener
los coeficientes positivos por aquí
entonces que me va a quedar si sumo todo
esto de ambos lados de la ecuación
bueno pues de este lado voy a obtener
que cero que es cero va a ser
exactamente igual que primero tengo a x
es cuadrada que voy a poner con este
color es cuadrada positiva ok y después
si yo sumo 7 por 10 de al menos 4 de
ambos lados éste va a cambiar de signo y
va a pasar del otro lado con signo
positivo estoy sumando de ambos lados 7
por 10 de la menos 4x
entonces me quedaría aquí positivo ok
más 7 por 10 a la menos 4
de lujo y después voy a tener que restar
de ambos lados de esta ecuación 10.5 por
10 a la menos 4 así que vamos a hacerlo
así resto de ambos lados esta cantidad
bueno pues ahora de este lado me va a
quedar negativa menos 10.5 por 10 a la
menos 4 y ahora si tengo aquí mi
ecuación cuadrática y ahora podemos
resolver esta ecuación de hecho vamos a
resolver esta ecuación y vamos a llegar
a la solución de esta ecuación
cuadrática pero antes quiero que veas
que podemos hacer una aproximación para
resolver esta ecuación cuadrática que
tenemos aquí es decir hacerlo un poco
más sencillo y un poco más fácil y para
esto déjame bajar un poco la pantalla
porque lo que quiero que veas es lo
siguiente si yo me tengo por aquí ha
muerto mejor aquí una caja esta caja me
va a decir mi aproximación bueno pues es
que esta aproximación sale de lo
siguiente si te das cuenta aquí este
término éste tiene lo que tenemos aquí
es mucho más grande que este término que
tenemos aquí o dicho de otra manera el
término que está al lado de la x cuadra
domina al término que está al lado de la
equis cuando tenemos valores
relativamente pequeños de x a
comparación de los valores que tenemos
de x cuadrada bueno simple sencillamente
los químicos miran este problema y dicen
hey sabes que si este término es mucho
más pequeño que el término que tenemos
aquí simple y sencillamente lo podemos
ignorar vamos a decir que no existe este
término y vamos a resolver una ecuación
cuadrática mucho más sencilla y entonces
el problema se vuelve muy simple porque
si ignoras este término
entonces sigue sin una ecuación
cuadrática pero te va a quedar lo
siguiente que x cuadrada y lo voy a
poner en este rectángulo rojo que es
nuestro rectángulo de la aproximación x
cuadrada va a ser exactamente igual a
este término lo vamos a ignorar y ahora
esto lo voy a pasar del otro lado de la
ecuación y entonces me quedaría que x
cuadrada es lo mismo que 10.5 ok por 10
elevado a la menos 4 lo cual es un
problema mucho más sencillo de resolver
porque no vamos a tener que utilizar la
fórmula cuadrática en realidad
a hacer en este cuadrado de aquí porque
no es una solución exacta es una
aproximación pero es una buena
aproximación se va a parecer mucho a
nuestra solución y entonces de aquí
puedo obtener que x va a ser igual en
esta aproximación que la raíz cuadrada
positiva de esto así que si ahora
traemos por acá nuestra calculadora
justo por acá ok
bueno pues ahora podemos resolver para x
porque si yo saco la raíz cuadrada ok de
dejar con el decir 10.5 que multiplica a
10 elevado elevado a la menos 4 ok
elevado a la menos 4 ok
bueno pues mi respuesta va a ser justo
esta raíz cuadrada que tenemos aquí lo
cual es a ser un punto 0 32/0 punto 0 30
y 24 así que antes de escribirlo aquí
esto nos daría de resultado
0.0 32
4 entonces este es el resultado que nos
da si utilizamos la pequeña
simplificación bastante bien y mucho más
fácil nuevo resuelto esencialmente para
nuestra concentración de hidrógeno está
de acuerdo el barrio tx lo que
representa x es justo esta parte que
tenemos aquí antes de no ponerlo así
este sería nuestro valor de x este de
aquí el cual sería 0.03 24 esto es lo
que valía x y una vez que ya tenemos la
concentración de hidrógeno bueno pues ya
va a ser muy fácil encontrar el ph en
este caso podríamos decir que el ph el
ph
bueno pues esencialmente es el logaritmo
en base 10 texto y nuestro resultado
negativo
así que si otra vez por acá traemos a
nuestra calculadora ok pues bueno ahora
fíjate que ya tenemos aquí nuestro
respuesta ya esto le voy a calcular el
lugar y tmo fíjate que aquí tengo el
luminismo en base 10 ok entonces el
menos y logaritmo en base 10 el ph de
nuestra respuesta anterior
va a ser exactamente igual que un 1.48 9
1.49 así que el ph en este caso en
nuestro caso que estamos simplificando
sería un 1.49 pero recuerda esto no está
resolviendo como tal en ecuación
cuadrática solamente me estoy tomando
una pequeña significación y fíjate que
llegó a un ph de 1.49 ahora qué te
parece si vemos que es lo que nos sale
si resolvemos completamente esta
ecuación cuadrática que tenemos aquí es
decir esta que tenemos justo por aquí
vamos a decir que el valor de x déjame
ponerlo justo aquí el valor de x es
exactamente igual que y me quedaría
menos ve aquí tengo a b entonces me va a
quedar menos 7 ok x 10 elevado a la
menos 4 ok más menos más menos la raíz
cuadrada de p cuadrada que es esto de
aquí es decir me quedaría el cuadrado de
estos siete por siete es 49 49
queipo 10 elevado a la y el cuadrado de
10 elevado a la menos 4 es multiplicar
esto por 2 10 elevado al menos 8 ok
menos déjame ponerlo con otro color
menos 4 veces hace menos 4 por 1 bueno
es 4 y ok y si lo multiplicó por seis me
va a quedar que menos por menos es más
ok más y aquí me quedan 10 puntos 5 por
bueno son fáciles 42 42 por 10 elevado a
la menos 4 al menos 4 y ahora tenemos
que dividir todo esto a todo esto entre
dos veces
pero a vale 1 por lo tanto entre 2 ok y
ahora vamos a explorar cuánto es esta
raíz cuadrada que tengo aquí y para eso
de nuevo traigamos nuestra calculadora
ok yo lo que quiero hacer es a la suma
de estos dos y sacar la raíz cuadrada
así que vamos a ver 49 ok que multiplica
a 10
elevado está por aquí al menos 8 ok a
esto
le quiero sumar déjame ponerlo en
paréntesis a esto le quiero sumar
bueno pues 42 a déjame ponerle a 19 suma
42 por 10 a la menos 4 ok que multiplica
que multiplica a 10 elevado a la menos 4
ok vamos a ponerlos y elevado a la menos
4 ok y si hacemos la suma de estos dos
deja ponerle un paréntesis esto me va a
dar esta cantidad de ti y ahora si a
esto le saco la raíz cuadrada voy a
obtener 0.06 48 entonces vamos a
escribir lo justo por acá ok y me va a
quedar entonces que x
es exactamente igual que menos 7 por 10
al menos 4 ok menos 7
ok por 10 elevado a la menos 4 + - y
bueno me había dado el resultado dejando
con este color 0.064 ahora en todo esto
habrá que dividirlo entre 2 ok para
obtener el valor de x ahora lo primero
que quiero que te des cuenta es que si
yo me tomo a este valor y le restó este
valor voy a obtener una cantidad
negativa por lo tanto no sería muy bueno
tener concentraciones negativas estás de
acuerdo entonces solamente nos vamos a
tomar la suma no le voy a hacer caso a
la diferencia de ellos porque si me tomo
la diferencia obtendría una
concentración negativa y entonces vamos
a hacerlo esto que tenemos aquí en
nuestra calculadora ok vamos a traerla
por acá ok y ahora lo que quiero es a
esta cantidad tomarme la suma de esto ok
con
ok 7 por 10 al menos 47 ok por 10
elevado a la menos 4 ok esto va a ser
igual a esta cantidad de aquí ya grant a
esto habrá que dividirlo entre 2 vivimos
entre 2 y obtenemos a justo este valor
que tenemos aquí x va a ser igual a 0.03
20 así que vamos escribirlo esto va a
ser igual a 0.03 2 y si te das cuenta es
muy cercano a lo que obtuvimos en
nuestra aproximación y ahora recuerda x
es lo que valía la concentración
usted lo tenemos por acá arriba la
concentración de hidrógeno esto de aquí
y por lo tanto ahora sí si yo quiero
calcular el ph de hannah bajar de nuevo
esta pantalla ok si ahora lo que quiero
es calcular el ph ya sé que la
concentración de hidrógeno ok en este
caso es lo mismo que 0.0 32 molar ok y
si ahora quiero calcular
h va a ser en menos ok y logaritmo en
base 10 de esto que tengo aquí 0.0 32 y
esto va a ser lo mismo que es hora de
sacar de nuevo nuestra calculadora y voy
a calcular el menos ok el logaritmo de
nuestra respuesta y esto va a ser lo
mismo que a 1.49 1.49 va a ser mi ph el
cual no estaba nada lejos de lo que
nosotros calculamos en nuestra
aproximación y ojo recuerda que hay que
poner que esté ph sale de tener 1.5 ok
molar de ácido fluorhídrico lo cual es
muy ácido sin embargo recuerda que
podemos tener ph más ácidos si nos
tomamos 1 molar de ácido clorhídrico
este tenía
a un ph de 0 los recuerdas y solamente
utilizando 1 molar de ácido clorhídrico
como sea esto es todo por este vídeo y
nos vemos en el siguiente